thank you denisha the program has had to
cancel a monday game against pepperdine
because a person in the program testing
positive
and now it's affected the coach of the
program and future games
head coach t.j otzelberger releasing a
statement today saying
that two different tests revealing he
tested positive for the virus he does
say
i appreciate the outstanding care of our
medical team
and now i'm required isolation he goes
on to say i look forward to returning to
this
team as soon as possible and in the
meantime i will remain connected to our
team remotely
he closes by saying i encourage everyone
to continue
to follow all the safety and health
guidelines as we battle this pandemic
together might also mention because of
the positive tests in the program the
games against
wyoming this weekend postponed the
league will try to
add them and make them up at a later
date unlv has already had to cancel a
few games now
and who knows what the future brings
with this pandemic seemingly changing
everything
all the time